three things
three things that what three things
three things people get fired for
how to keep your job
number one
i think the number one flag for me as
if i was in any sort of leadership
position
if i give someone critical feedback
in just sort of a direct way not a mean
way
and they
instead of addressing it or being honest
about it
or
really anything
they just go anti-social
they just ball up they don't hear for
from for days
you have no idea if they're trying to
correct it you have no idea
what's going on
you don't want that person back
there's a lot of reasons why but i think
the main reason is
you just have no idea what what's going
on there's just a lack of communication
for all you know they could show up one
day with with the gun and shoot
everybody and it's because you gave them
feedback which is [ __ ] stupid
so what's the proper way to do it
well
you address it that's it you say okay
you see it from from as many
perspectives as you can and you try to
improve that's it
everybody needs feedback everybody needs
to be told they're doing something wrong
every once in a while it's just sort of
a
fact of growing
if nobody ever tells you you're doing
something the wrong way you're going to
keep doing it the wrong way you're just
going to keep messing things up and it's
not good for anybody especially at a
company that's trying to advance
so i think that's the number one thing
uh the number one reason why people
would get fired is just
basically turning the antisocial
it's it's pretty it's pretty foolish
thing to do
number
two
i guess this sort of is like number one
but
it's not number one it's number two
not trying
now
i'm not sure how anyone would get hired
to begin with with if they're not trying
but there are some
jobs where they just kind of need
someone anyone so they just accept
whoever applies and
interviews decently
they say all right come aboard we'll
give you a chance
and then when that person shows up
they're running late all the time
uh they don't really have
uh the type of mind that can figure out
things on their own they need constant
direction
or they're just not doing anything at
all and when you do give them direction
they they're they're all pissy about it
it's like what
why are you even here go go do something
that makes you happy
so
i think that's the number two thing that
gets people fired is they're just not
trying
number three
now as i'm sitting here thinking of
these there are a lot more than three
things that get people fired but
a big number three for me is if someone
comes comes in unprepared all the time
like if they
look very unkempt
no pun intended because i kind of looked
that way right now
but i just took a shower that's kind of
why anyway uh
this isn't grease it's water it's water
guys calm down
very unkept like if someone comes in and
they smell like ass every day
and just annoys the crap out of
everybody
and they're they're obviously just you
know not really caring about the
appearance of themselves or the company
or anything
they have to go they're just bringing
everybody else down so all three of
these things as you might notice don't
just affect the person who is
who has the absolutely shitty behavior
they affect the entire workplace they
affect the company and that's
why it is management's best decision
to can yo ass
at that point
well that's going to do for this video
thanks for tuning in hope this helps
somebody out there i know these are
really obvious but
i think some people like don't know this
stuff oddly enough so i thought i'd make
a video all right
take it easy guys see you in the next
one